agne hier soir des incidents perturber
le spectacle de dieudonné avec
manifestation à l'extérieur de la salle
et à l'intérieur un climat très tendu
qui accompagne la polémique qui s'est
installé après les propos jugés
antisémites de l'humoriste aurélia guim
le spectacle est commencée depuis
quarante cinq minutes le voilà déjà
interrompt dans la salle une bouteille
contenant un produit irritant vient
d'être jeté un spectateur tout chez elle
il doit être hospitalisé
comme égales pour pas commandant avec
l'alarmé a été déclenchée donc pension
l'évacuation est recommandée mais ni
dieudonné ni son public ne voit les
choses de cet oeil
il faut dire qu'il ya soir à lyon venir
assister à la représentation n'était pas
de tout repos
fouille au corps systématiques à
l'entrée de la salle tandis que dehors
environ 200 manifestants étaient venus
protester contre les propos de
l'humoriste jugés antisémites
on est là pour se défendre on est là
pour être comme tous les êtres humains
est encore vivant comme ça il y a
quelques jours la ville des lions elle
même avait décidé l'annulation du
spectacle pour risque de trouble à
l'ordre public mais cette fois
l'humoriste a eu raison devant le
tribunal administratif
après que quatre autres villes l'ont
retirée de la fiche après le spectacle
comique affaire bi essam e bonds coluche
en d'autres temps était interdit de
service public
je prends ça comme comme une médaille
comme un passage obligatoire pour un
bouffon la cool
au lendemain de son spectacle dieudonné
a annoncé qu'il portait plainte pour
violences et voies de fait les incidents
qui pourrait bien encourager d'autres
deals annulé ses représentations